having a wonderful two days talk and
this morning we are honored to have
professor chaplain from Quran and NYU
Shanghai created an agile
probabilistically to what I and this may
be the fundamental contributions of
relation theory in glass very
interesting workshop for me expected my
bicycle I made a mistake this morning
I'm thinking thinking the rain had
stopped well that's not attend started
again but I brought an extra pair of
pants so right so that this will mostly
be a kind of historical historical
review so that I put down here to to
review papers with one quite recent
which is a sort of extended version of
this talk which is on the archive will
appear in the bulletin of the American
masses IT another one which is an older
one about it's in principle related and
it would be very interesting to try to
find more relations it's about
connections between Brownian motion and
zeta function and C functions
therefore the Riemann hypothesis
unfortunately it doesn't don't seem to
be any connections so if I discovered
that related to easing models and
using models are as we know from talk
talks already
Italy and they will the lianca theorem
is about zeros of partition functions
and easing models and it would be
tremendous to try to figure out some
relation for example with with the
Brownian motion connections to the zeta
function but that hasn't been discovered
yet okay right so so I'll get to briefly
talk about things related to the lutely
and Young's theorem later if I don't run
out of time but the first main part of
the talk is really about moment
generating functions or Laplace
transforms and in their connection with
the C function and that's that's that's
a very old thing it goes back to a
Riemann's original paper so here's the
here's the setup
so we consider a function f will be
interested in a very particular function
which I'll write down in a moment the
functions that we'll be dealing with
will be functions that are positive and
even positive in and will be even and
ones interested forget this forget this
of factor with a lambda for a moment if
without that if F has a hate goes to 0
fast enough at infinity then this
two-sided Laplace transform will be
well-defined for complex W and will be
an entire function of complex W even if
that's not the case for given F if you
put in this factor with lambda negative
then you will get something which is
decreasing factor not fast enough to
give you a entire function of complex
though
and for some functions f like the kind
that come up in the Riemann hypothesis
you can put even a positive lambda
because F decreases at infinity very
rapidly and so anyway this will be
defined for any lambda any real lambda
for which would make sense and then it
will typically be a higher function of
complex W sometimes we'll think of the f
of udu as a because the f is positive at
least if you multiplied by a very
constant you can think of well you have
multiplied by constant you can think of
after you as a as a for L measure on the
real line and and sometimes you
normalize it to make it a probability
measure so that that's the general setup
what does this have to do is we're gonna
positive as well has to do with a
particular choice of f so there's a
specific function they take f to be the
specific function capital Phi which is
actually this function of you real you
that's the only thing you need to see
from this is that for any real you
because this term goes to 0 very rapidly
it's a nicely converging serious so it's
a will define real function for real you
and the as we'll see in a moment this
function this function decreases very
rapidly that's for for large you that's
kind of obvious for a large positive you
it's not so obvious to start with for a
large negative view but that that is the
case and so even without the little
lambda so this is a little class
transform with a little m that it being
0 it will be a nice entire function of
complex w so it's that particular choice
of Phi is important because as I said
already
Raymond's 1859 paper that's one one of
the formulations of the Riemann
hypothesis and is in terms of every
month see function which is actually
actually is up to a multiplicative
constant is this function this Laplace
transform with little lambda being zero
and except that there's a change of
variables the the s of the zeta function
and now when you multiply by these extra
factors that's the C function the
critical line for the zeros of their
hypothesis are real part of s equals one
half so one just one just translates
that by half and then that's zeros in
the W plane our critical line
corresponds to the imaginary axis so the
Riemann hypothesis is equivalent to the
statement that this particular Laplace
transform of this particular cost
transform of this particular function
Phi has all of zeros are in the are pure
imaginary are on the critical line which
is now than translated to the imaginary
axis okay so now let me make let me make
a few comments about this function so
one is that even though it doesn't look
like it this is an even function of U
the evenness of this function Phi is the
same as the as the so called as
Riemann's functional equation for the
zeta function or the Z function which
looks a little different because of the
change of variables because we
translated by 1/2 it's simply evenness
of the function Phi so that's a it
doesn't look even but it is I'll show
you a numerical graph of this function
and
so that's at least numerically that will
verify the three properties I'm about to
say so one is the evenness another
property is that it's rapidly decreasing
as I said it's that's obvious when you
is large and positive it goes to zero
very rapidly like e to minus an
exponential it's not so clear what
happens when u is large and negative but
once you know that Phi is even then it
does the same thing for a large negative
you so it's rapidly decreasing the other
property is that this is a positive
function of U so that's elementary for
you greater than or equal to zero
because you can just check that these
terms here are termed by these this
pre-factor is where each n is
non-negative Elementary exercise that is
not the case when u is negative but it
doesn't matter because in spy's an even
function once you know it's positive or
positive you it's also positive for
negative u so so those are three useful
properties very rapidly decreasing even
and non negative here's a here's what
the graph looks like this is zero so you
can see that for you bigger than about
0.4 it's you know practically equal to
zero of course it's not zero but it
decreases extremely rapidly like e to
the minus x potential other than that
it's not I mean it's not a very
remarkable looking function and so it's
sort of somehow striking that the famous
Riemann hypothesis is just has to do
with the Laplace transform of this
particular function you know what could
be so hard about that
but of course you know you need to prove
something about the Laplace transform of
this function not something that looks
like this function right so yeah so this
numerically verifies the evenness and
the fact that rapidly decreasing and the
positivity because zero zero is over
here somewhere please interrupt me if
you have any no evenness is already done
in three months paper yeah I'm just
saying that if you want to see numerical
here's a picture well I you know I just
stepped just visually what I said I just
said it looks on spec tactically it
doesn't go it's pretty close to zero
already at zero point four there's
nothing special about zero point four
though I'm not sure what's special about
it
I am you
okay so here's some history so as I say
that this formulation of the internet
process already appears in Riemann's
original paper that Ramana did not have
this extra lambda factor polio was the
one who introduced this perturbation you
know what let me go let me go back so so
we begin with we begin with this F being
that kept that particular capital Phi
can little M the equal zero so you just
have the Laplace transform there's no no
extra Gaussian factor polio was the one
who had the idea well let's let's sort
of perturb the see function by this by
this factor and see you know if that
helps understand things actually there
other ways one could perturb it and
there's a recent preprinted dan Romek
who's in the audience which does
different kind of perturbation or
related kinds of perturbations this was
the one that polio oh yeah first did and
and his idea was a so exciting so here's
a may have introduced this in a previous
like Piz is just an abbreviation for the
purpose of this talk of pure imaginary
zeros by the pure imaginary service
property that all the zeroes in the
complex plane of this Laplace transform
are pure I'm the pure imaginary I'm the
imaginary axis and polio seem to hope oh
I thought it might be possible that even
with the perturbation no matter what
sign the perturbation was maybe the
zeros were always on the imaginary axis
and of course if that were the case then
that would include little m2 equals zero
which is the case that you're really
interested in the universe's he also
studied this kind of question and showed
for example that as you vary lambda
once you have any value of lambda where
you have the pure imaginary zeros
property then increasing lambda doesn't
hurt that kind of only helps it so
increasing lambda sort of helps or
doesn't hurt the pure imaginary zeros
property decreasing it could could hurt
it but maybe it doesn't so as I said
seem that Polly I thought maybe even
when you made lambda negative even
arbitrarily large and negative maybe you
also have the pure imaginary service
property if that were true then you know
that you could try to prove that more
general thing and that would keep you as
a corollary my father says right so then
the next kind of major development was
in 1950 paper by the dutch mathematician
i usually say that the way it looks like
an english de brian but that's I'm told
by my Dutch friends that that's
disgustingly wrong pronunciation it
should be something like I'll stop
trying to do it so anyway the blinder
ground had the tape of paper in 1950
which proved that even if whether
nothing our fathers is true which is the
imaginary zeros property when little m2
equals zero if you help it enough
basically by making this a lambda equal
to one-half or bigger then the zero
certainly are in the curvature on the
imaginary axis and that was an argument
based on the fact that you already know
that the zeroes are in the critical
strip and and it serve as a kind of an
extension of pelléas arguments not only
not only does making lambda more
positive from zero help or not hurt but
it actually helps it helps enough that
it squeezes zeros which might have been
off the imaginary axis within the strip
all the way onto the imaginary axis so
once you get to lend equals one-half
that puts everything in that strip
which is where all the zeroes were onto
the pier imaginary axis so so that that
so it's okay so that was that was a
major result so then then there's a
paper of mine in 1976 I'll if I don't
run out of time I'll explain later
what I was why I was studying this I
wasn't interested at the time they're
gonna pass this but interested in some
Cisco physics things related to
Euclidean quantum field theories which
motivated us study of some questions and
as a kind of byproduct of that one got
result about about this perturbed see
function and which turned out to be more
interest than the Klien field theory
questions that motivated it anyway the
result was basically that this hope of
pulley is what was not valid and that is
to say if you make lambda sits a Gnostic
about three hypotheses but it says if
you make land the sufficiently negative
then the kind of hurting direction at
some point you will not have all pure
imaginary zeros so there exist some
lambda basically especially negative but
still finally negative so that you don't
have the pure imaginary service rifles
zeros come off the real axis absolute
magic axis eventually so if you combine
that with polios monotonously result and
the brines live result about what
happens when the land equals one half it
conclude that there is some kind of
critical value of little lambda which is
which is called your capital lambda
somewhere between minus infinity and 1/2
so that you have the pure edge reserves
property you don't have it up to lambda
but you do have it starting from capital
lambda and above this this has since
become known as the
in constant and since you're really
interested for their hypothesis in the
case when little m20 they're gonna
father's this can be restated as the
equivalent to the statement that this
this number capital lambda is less than
or equal to zero so let me kind of
restate some of these things next so so
this was the result of the brine 1950
was that this constant was quickly less
than or equal to one-half my result was
really that it was strictly greater than
minus infinity and then also in that
paper I conjectured that it was greater
than equal to zero so that means that
well if it's greater than zero then
they're impulses is false if it's equal
to zero during our fathers this is true
but any small perturbation by taking
little lambda even slightly negative
would have some non pure imaginary zeros
so I in that paper I said this
conjecture was quantitative version of
the statement that if they're in palaces
if it's true is only barely so in the
sense that any any small perturbation of
this sort in a bad direction gets to the
zeros off the measure axis so I've been
asked that a few times and I I like my
memory is that I saw some more classic
paper which said something of this sort
I mean wasn't about this this lambda
yeah that it's fragile but I tried to
look back and look at some of the papers
that I probably looked at and I couldn't
find the paper that so I'm not sure
there was such a paper whether I
just imagining it yeah so so so I can't
I'm fortunate like Kent shed a great
deal of light yeah well but that's right
so I mean hope that this this hope that
you can make perturbation arbitrarily
negative that's already was this proof
in my paper but but yes what would you
say is correct yeah so I have a I have a
kind of complicated joke about this sort
of issue but it would take too much but
it's you know it's well we'll see that
in a short league that that because of
recent developments which I'll get to
which is a year old of Rogers and Tao
the river that father's is now known to
be equivalent to this constant means
zero so so I have a personal personal
event I desire that the rent publicist
not be true because if the rate of
publicist is true and it's unlikely that
the constant will continue to be called
this there's a further version of that
which you notice there's joke part but I
you know projection amplifies the
Riemann hypothesis it says that all the
zeroes are simple it it if the zeroes
were not simple then that would already
impulse I mean yes it may become not
simple before they yes that's correct as
you vary the little lambda before sets
off the real axis they have to kind of
come together and yes and then move off
that's correct okay so so not now some
in the history of this conjecture so as
it's oh well my result was basically
there was strictly greater than minus
infinity that's not a very impressive
bound but you know there's something and
the drawings was that Celeste was born
half so there's up there
there were our improvements and there
was a whole sequence of paper starting
from 88 in which in which actual bounds
other than strictly greater than minus
if any were gotten starting from minus
50 and then improving and skipping most
of them improving to a fairly small
negative number and then even smaller
over here and then more recently this
bit up further they have much better
lower bound which we'll get to in a
second and the only improvement of the
upper bound was instead of less than
equal to a half was strictly less than
one-half that's a paper of about ten
years ago Pete Kim and Lee this doesn't
look like much of an improvement but
it's actually it is much more
significant than it looks like because
there are other things in that paper
that are quite quite useful so maybe
I'll get to
so as far as the lower bound the you
know this this sequence of improvements
was all consistent with the conjecture
this conjecture that it's greater than
equal to zero was you know but obviously
then prove it
but that has been changed recently I
mean that's originally a year ago little
over a year ago so there's a paper of
red Rogers in Tarrytown in which they
actually prove that conjecture and the
basis of the roughly speaking the the
basis of the proof is to that all these
improvements were based on so as Elliott
said the when in order for things to
move off the real axis basically zeroes
on the imaginary axis have to come
together and appear and then move off in
a pair off the imaginary axis and so if
there's a pair of zero under the
imaginary axis but very close together
it shouldn't take much to preserve them
to come together in move off and so you
the lower bounds were gotten by looking
at very close pairs of zeros near each
other on the imaginary axis now way up
on the imaginary axis on there but
what-what Rogers in town did was kind of
you know do a more robust version of
that argument in which you didn't look
at single pairs of zeros but that's kind
of distribution of the spacings of the
zeros and so it was bait you know it
used some of those ideas and other ones
and back back from these specific bounds
and and they study the motions of these
zeros as you vary this parameter lambda
which you know
kind of time and that this this is this
equation is actually satisfy go
backwards heat equation and parameter T
or lambda and and you can study that and
then also hire them in a sort of roughly
speaking that if the if the capital
lambda were negative then you already
for that negative value of T you would
already have zeros on the imaginary axis
and now you move T from the small
negative value toward zero and that
would give you a certain motion of those
zeros which would tend to make the
spacings get more separated than to kind
of repel each other the zeros right down
the system info ease that the zero
satisfied to kind of repel each other
and so these spacings would get more
regular and it would get regular enough
that by the time you've got two T equals
zero
there would be spacings would be
sufficiently regular that they would
violate no results about the
distribution of the spacings of the
actual zeta function zeros assuming the
rena pollicis which are allowed to
assume in the context of this proof okay
so that's about you know the upper bound
and the lower bound has now been
improved well I should say as much as
possible perhaps somebody will prove
that it's strictly greater than 0.1 is
for three times 10 to the minus 15 I
told this proves they're going to
publish this but sure I'm short of a
discrete figure and I pollicis that
that's about as you can can't do any
better than with the lower bound the
upper bound Oh remember that the
redeposits is actually equivalent to the
lambda being less than or equal to zero
because now we know it can't be less
than zero so now it's a
the evil is zero and so the principle
you know if you did a sequence of upper
bounds which improves the one half going
down to zero that that would prove their
inner palaces so that's you would have
heard it if then it happened but they it
has been or is being improved so there's
one of the polymath project number 15
which you could look up now eleven
threads about its online has been
working on improving the lower bound
better than one-half this so basically
it's gotten as far as getting a little
sorry an upper bound improving from one
half and its value down to zero point
two two it says here as of October 2018
which gives you a hint when these slides
were here but it actually is still the
same the possibility of getting down to
zero point one one is is it would
require misuses you know all kinds of
machinery including very substantial
numerical computations but which can be
can be made rigorous you it but you
would need even more numerical
computations which would be of a sort of
you know verifying that the zeros up to
even farther than people have gotten
along the imaginary axis oh you know in
going up are still on the imaginary axis
and if that we're done enough you could
possibly get done at zero point one one
that's the that's what that's what seems
to be the case it does not seem likely
it does not seem likely that this kind
of argument without some extra new
ingredient will lead to a proof of the
real hypothesis and from my point of
view that's because it's not using using
models and we are
unfortunately I don't know how to do it
that way either
anyway so one comment is that these
improved upper bounds are using the key
Kim and Lee results not just that they
strictly less than one half but they had
another result for example that when you
make a little lambda positive even very
small and positive you already know that
there are only finally many zeros off
the imaginary axis so that that piece of
information is very useful in getting
these improved upper bounds okay I have
could I be my own timer there's nothing
okay so here's I do have some time to
talk about the mathematical physics of
statistical physics background and it's
it's related to the theorem of eliyahu
we've heard we've heard this discussion
several several lectures from the point
of view of this talk the the the the are
the two comments one is that by taking
an easing model of the sort that the
applies to and then taking positive
linear combinations of the easing spin
variables that gives you a random
variable whose moment generating
function which whoops moment generating
function which is this well with the
would say with the with the first lambda
equals zero is is the partition function
for that easing model and and and how
Liang theorem is often correctly
described as a circle theorem but that's
about zeros on the unit circle here on
the imaginary axis because there's a
change of variables and basically
looking at you know eat the e to the
points on the circle R sorry eat ether
the points an imaginary axis are the
points on the unit circle so it's a
simple change of variables depends on
whether you think of easing model as a
model of a lattice gas or a model of
plus or minus 1 variables and
anyway so so it gives you random
variables whose distribution probability
distribution row has a moment generating
function which is this thing with little
m equals 0 which has the pure imaginary
0 property and that's very useful as I
think as I leave discussed very useful
in statistical physics that's why Lee
and Jung were interested in it and it's
also useful for our related subject
which is called Euclidean field theory
including quantum field theory in that
related subject you want to study
variables which are not just values plus
or minus 1 but take real values and so
you replace you replace the measure
which is the sum of two point masses at
plus one and minus one by some measure
with the density or e to the minus V of
various forms and then if they're useful
to have a lee and jung type result for
those those kinds of models those are
those are lattice field lattice
Euclidean field theories okay it's
particularly useful because of some
unnatural within that setting to put in
this this pulley a kind of factor where
you put in the e to the lambda u squared
or here it's not change to e to the
minus B U squared and if you can put in
the if if the polla idea which isn't the
case for the capital Phi if it were the
case for this function that you could
put in a little m there with any sign
that would be very useful in the
Euclidean field theory context because
it allow you to put in a a mass term
with arbitrary choice of the mass and
that would be very nice
so so for the purposes of this talk it's
a bad choice of language but anyway I'm
calling such a such a function f of the
form
viii perfect if you can perturb it even
with a in the bad direction even with a
negative lambda and still have the pure
imaginary zeros property well there are
examples of such things well of course
the yeah I mean the the easing case
where it's not a function but it's a sum
of two point masses of course it's fine
because you multiplied by e to the minus
the you square that doesn't change
anything except there's a normalization
but but there are other examples where
that's known and here's here's the most
well-known one
it's where the function V is a fourth
degree even fourth degree polynomial so
it looks like this and you can put in
arbitrary lambda or an arbitrary be
positive or negative and you still have
this pure imaginary zeros property so in
the in the quantum field theory context
that was a result of discovered by Simon
and Griffiths it actually was already
known by polio in the 1920s because he
studied things with Fourier transforms
and certainly zeroes of course police
result wouldn't be quite enough in the
Euclidean field theory context because
you need a multivariate version of it
that a single variable version which you
get from the Simon Griffith result but
anyway that that's an example so what
motivated me in that 76 paper was I
wondered whether there were other things
besides the fourth degree polynomial so
one is uh if you want an even function
and so an exponential interaction would
be something like a hyperbolic cosine so
I was interested whether that thing was
perfect in this in this language so
exponential or hyperbolic cosine field
theory we do have a lead young type
result for arbitrary a little lambda or
arbitrary a little B that's what I was
set out to I'm hoping that would be the
case in the process of studying that in
fact I basically characterized all
perfect s and that class of F's which I
won't get to it but in a later slide
that actually
write down what that class is it did not
include this one that was I was it
started out being an interest so that
was a negative results about that
shouldn't you feel theory model
on the other hand it also did not
include the capital v Riemann hypothesis
well that's also a negative result in
the sense that pelléas hope is wrong but
that's sort of interesting in that the
number theory setting it seems and so
that so that paper I wrote was about
know that that side of things and that
that was the result that showed that
this capital land it was greater than
mice infinity and therefore was a
well-defined constant so that's the
that's that's the history of that's a
history of somehow how the Cisco physics
leon type thing motivated motivated that
that that's a paper so so now in a few
minutes remaining i wanted to mention a
few a few more recent things and these
are discussed in in much more detail
obviously in this in this review paper
this is quite recent review paper here
so so here's an example of of a result
so so this so that you know so one often
comes up with a functions little a four
measures zero and you want to know
whether whether whether you have a Lian
type property or imagine a zero spike
property or not and here's an example of
a negative result fairly general so
here's a case where unlike unlike in the
renter positives case where the road
that you're interested in is has density
capital v which is very rapidly
decreasing suppose you have something
which is not rapidly decreasing at all
is it's so non rapidly decreasing that
you cannot if you put in a gaussian
factor with lambda positive it will no
no longer no longer be no longer be
integrable so for example I don't know a
symmetrized exponential distribution
causes there only e to the minus
absolute you or something even slower
you know constant over a Cauchy
distribution or constant over one plus u
squared city to the twelfth power so so
if you put in a positive lamb that's no
longer integral then the theorem is that
now if you put in a negative lambda of
course it will be night have a nice
Gaussian tail but and you can ask is the
moment is the moment generating function
or Laplace transform have only have only
have this pure imaginary zeros property
and the answer is no for every positive
land for every every negative lambda
even though the moment generating
function or a Laplace transform is not a
nice entire function it is does not have
only pure imaginary zeros so that's a
you know it's somewhat somewhat
interesting negative result but the the
proof of it is I I find more interesting
and it's based on what I think I still
think is somewhat surprising result
about convergence of probability
measures which I'll state in a moment I
won't talk about this connection
remember very clearly but here's the
convergence result
so it it ties together the pyramid
generous property of moment-generating
functions and we convergence of
probability measures in a somewhat
unexpected way so here here's the
theorem
so-sorry defined a class of random
variables it's really a class of their
probability distributions so the random
variables are even so the probability
distribution is symmetric with respect
to reflection about the origin it has at
least Gaussian tail fall off so you can
unlike the example I was talking about
before so that you can multiply by a
exponential with a small positive B at
least for small positive B and still get
something interval and it has this pure
imaginary zeroes property of its moment
generating function that that's this
class the theorem is that if you have a
sequence of such variables and
importantly you make no assumption about
uniformity of what B you can put in
there so the the B could beginning very
small as n gets large so even though you
have a Gaussian tail the tail could
could could get getting weaker you know
worse and worse and if you have a
limiting distribution which is a very
weak kind of limit in really measures it
just says the Fourier transform
converges point-wise on the real line
normally that's not enough to even know
that the limiting variable has a second
moment but in this case somehow the pure
imaginary xerus property tells you that
just knowing we convergence even though
there's no uniformity at all in this b
bang on in the limiting variable is in
this class in particular has to have at
least Gaussian fall off so there's
something something something mysterious
about that I mean a less mysterious than
it first looks because somehow even
though you don't assume that B is
uniform the pure interest property
implies at the end that it is uniform or
else you couldn't have the weak
convergence like the oceans of Globus do
with H love you g if you say so both can
do it just from the lytic functions well
no no so if you make the assumption that
this B of X variable is it was uniform
then it would follow from its yes it's
somehow somehow will you get the
uniformity seemingly for free yeah of
course it's not for free because you
have to know about the zero sir I'm what
and what but do you get so you get
uniformity yes yes and what is that what
is that engine would that be physic you
could say a few words I can say a few
words and then I guess I will stop since
then yeah the okay actually let me go to
a formula all right sorry
so so the key is the as has come up
before another talk so the key is once
you know about the zeroes then you can
write a hidamari factorization for this
moment generating function product over
the zeros and it looks like this the
word is if you put the zeros and they
come in two pairs as you combine the two
pairs and furthermore the second moment
by this is a moment generating function
the second moment is the second Taylor
coefficient and that's related to the be
appearing here and is and these zeros
plus or minus iy k are zeros by this
formula so so so the proof is sort of in
two parts one is that if you make a much
weaker assumption than uniformity of the
bees just that the second moments are
uniformly bounded then because of this
identity that tells you something about
the zeros and so that's enough to get
much more you much more uniformly than
you thought the second step is that just
the we convergent is enough to show
again using this identity but now
replacing Z by I T so you're looking at
the Fourier transform is enough to show
that you couldn't get even because of
this formula you could get even the the
convergence and distribution of the of
the Fourier transform on the real axis
without having a uniform bound on the
second moments and so it's kind of in
two steps
okay so yeah that's it thank you
[Applause]
so
so that's how you do things
the degrees proof was based on that this
operator e to the negative lambda d
square it shrinks the size of a yes yes
and he produced a lot of other operators
do not too well so it so can you
it's not going to look at other type of
toxin C may look at this is a flu right
there's a lot of similar bills yeah so I
think that's exactly the point of view
so anyway I basically basically I agree
with that I don't think there has been
too much work of that sort and of course
a priori isn't clear it could be useful
but yeah yes yeah but the clothes that I
have been Chris don't have anyone to
missus a property
unfortunately so they have other nice
there's a derivative of the zeta
function have any interesting or
supposedly interesting property we would
talk about zeroes on the imaginary axis
this what if I look at the derivative
well the derivative with respect to
lambda I seeing am I expected to see
anything interesting it's a wire
question so you can give a while then
yeah yes I don't know what it is yeah as
I say there's Intel papers you know
studies that motion and which is a
backwards heat equation
something which is a recent part of that
that's where all my different directing
the recent part of that polymath 15 is
that they've been studying numerically
what happens when you said it if you
take the lambda to be say large and
negative now you're off the real axis
the zeros many of them some are still
there and they study the locations of
them and they seem to come in very
interesting patterns with say trying to
understand it's not clear what what
comment was that in that that might lead
to some improve proof of that
the result that I just improve my
federal conjecture but that's going off
in a different direction but I've been
anyway I met I think things like that
should be interesting but I have a
question Sunday is there any sort of
related development if you were to look
at the generalized various characters so
yeah so roughly speaking I'm the wrong
person to ask that question to since I'm
pretty ignorant about analytic number
theory but I have seen papers that have
to do with generalizations of my
conjecture two other related functions
some of which are having proved I think
some of which have been disproved so
that
Jim did you have it but so I just wanted
to make a comment there's other recent
paper by ten unknowns like
yeah survey as well which poll is that
one another approach of polio what's
called the Jensen polynomials or you
want to say something with that I think
you better say so I don't know that much
about it I've got a more than me just
something I think might interest people
here it's a very recent is it's on the
hour
yes I have a different comment which may
or may not be related to with Jim there
may that ask but the so the I saluted to
this before the so so I oh I talked
about the lean lean young reason I'm
also a central topic or one of the
topics of this this workshop I talked
about the lean young result that was a
kind of motivation for the paper I did
but you know wasn't really about that it
was the the so that as I said the Lee
and young theorem gives you a mechanism
for generating random variables or their
distributions are really measures on the
real line which have this pure imaginary
service property of their moment
generating function or Laplace transform
it is you know potentially their
analysis could be proved if one could
find some sequence of easing models and
such I hope linear combinations of this
bin variables puzzle an accommodation of
the spin variables and then limits of
those things where in the limit you
would get exactly the distribution whose
density is proportional to the function
that particular function Phi so nobody
nobody knows how to do that so the you
know the Leon clear mr. ko potentially
sort of thing there is a machine that
could give the last step in the proof
but the first West but the first step or
steps know is the hard part of finding
the right easing model or sequence of
easing miles that would give you that
particular pepper and by
on the other hand if you if you go to
that an old review paper of the end man
in your you will find that's something
that was known somewhat before the then
that that somewhat funny-looking capital
Phi arises in natural ways from other
probabilistic settings like Brownian
motion of riding excursions
unfortunately there is well I think I
wrote that down that doesn't seem to be
any relation between those Brownian
motion way of getting the function Phi
and easing models if there were maybe
you could put together the two things
and kind of you know do something but so
that so that the the the easing models
easy models give you a way to show the
right property of the zeros of
generating functions Brownian motions or
run excursions give you a way of
generating the right Phi so each of
these things has kind of half of an
argument and it doesn't seem to be so
far any relation between those two
things so that you combine the two
halves so that that would be you know a
good exercise for this workshop
but
yes I see context just sign flips yes
that's exactly correct so that's so so
so then barrel ooh someone's looking at
our puzzling their combinations of the
spin variables it's in an easing well
where you have pair of ferromagnetic
interactions and the Gibbs distributions
but no magnetic field except that that
you know that's kind of hiding it in the
moment-generating function the variable
is the magnetic field but but absolutely
correct so you're doing these and while
in which ravenna very we looking at is a
sum of spin variables that is symmetric
under flipping all the spins because you
don't have the magnetic field terms
linear term in the appeasing Hamiltonian
so it's manifestly symmetric
distribution this distribution Phi is
even but it's not manifestly even that
takes an argument and similarly the the
thing that comes up from Brownian motion
of writing a excursion once you pick out
the right of all factors his turns out
to be even but is not manifestly even
and so that that mystery of so where the
evenness comes from in that case maybe
if you figured out some hidden relation
or easing models that would that would
answer that question along with the
Riemann hypothesis because she would be
so interested in I mean it would be a
minor point yes that's right this is
manifestly even yeah I should
the big problem 480 probably trying to
read piecing to the stuff in some way
the in my opinion the grounded
developments contributed nothing it's
almost because in the end you don't get
anything more than you know a random
variable that has this density and you
don't get any analytic handle on it
besides what you already have from the
number theoretic setting and knowing the
audience eerie and so on
nobody's yet ever or to my knowledge
being able to prove anything I'm sort of
interesting about these functions that
wasn't already no it's just
oh these functions are the probability
densities of certain variables which are
very appealing nice to think about but
the trend that transfer of information
is all in the direction of known facts
about this fee function my rather
extraordinary facts about the Brownian
excursions but though used to hit the
question which is related now which is
not so [ __ ] brown name oh yes right
yeah so I mean as soon as you've got
that e to the minus something Z Swit you
know you're in a Gaussian world and you
want to do something yeah
any other questions that's even started
thank you thank you very much we got